can you unpack what shakedown means to
you
yeah shaketown basically means extortion
people are used to thinking of extortion
in the context of uh you know what the
mafia does
they you know they visit a local uh uh a
butcher shop
in buffalo new york and and they
basically say look if you want to
pay protection money it'd be terrible if
something happened to this shop
pay protection money and we'll make sure
that nothing happens well
that's extortion we all recognize that's
illegal we've seen that in movies
some people have experienced that uh
government
oftentimes can function the same way
there are many members of congress that
use tools and techniques
that aren't widely discussed i've
written about them members of congress
have talked to me about them
uh they have something called a milker
bill a milker bill
it doesn't have anything to do with the
dairy industry it's designed to milk
money from certain industries so how
does a milker bill work
well if i'm the chairman of a powerful
committee in congress
and i need to raise money or let's say i
need to find a
a lobbying opportunity for my son
i'm going to introduce a bill in
congress to let's say
put a 20 surtax on the high-tech
industry in silicon valley now
i don't actually believe in this bill i
don't even necessarily want this bill to
pass
but what's going to happen is that when
i introduce that bill
i'm going to have a flood of lobbyists
from silicon valley come
and say congressman schweitzer why are
you introducing this bill
and what will happen over the next 60
days is a dance
whereby they will come and meet they
will hold fundraisers for me
they will write campaign checks to me
they might even hire my son or my nephew
as a lobbyist for them this happens all
the time
my question fundamentally is how is that
any different
than the shakedown of the shop owner in
buffalo new york
it's the same form of extortion it's the
same element that says
look something bad is going to happen to
you i'm going to take
more money away unless you pay me
protection money now
and that happens in washington dc all
the time and it's the kind of extortive
behavior
um that's become all too familiar in
washington i think that
there's sort of a myth a lot of people
feel that the problem in washington is
that there's all this money
flowing into washington that
corporations and businesses around the
world
are just happy to send their money to
washington dc
they don't really want to but they feel
like they have to because if they don't
bad things are going to happen to them
and that's exactly what the political
class in washington
wants them to believe because it's so
lucrative for the political class
so business model number one introduce a
bill that you have no interest in
to scare off whoever it is in any kind
of an industry
meat technology health care whatever it
may be
then wait for the lobbyists of those
companies to reach out to you
to say hey you know we don't think this
is a good bill can we change your mind
et cetera et cetera
then what happens because is it a way of
me paying
your campaign or is it site money
what happens next because that's the
question it's great question oftentimes
it's campaign money
um uh actually in my book extortion uh
there's an example
from uh from uh congressman uh sorry
from uh
a gentleman named mr hofmeister who's
the ceo of shell oil
and he described the meeting that he had
in 2009 you remember in 2009
oil prices pretty eye he sat before a
congressional committee
members of congress including maxine
waters essentially said we want to
nationalize your company
we think it's outrageous the profits
you're making hofmeister reported to me
and i put in my book
that after that meeting congressman
waters
talked to him and said i might
understand your
issue better if we spend some time
together and this was basically
saying you need to raise money for me
and i will take the threat for
nationalizing your business away
so what you're doing is you're having a
series of coded conversations but you
know
exactly what's going on a shakedown is
taking place
and the beauty or the genius of a milker
bill is
you don't actually want it to pass if i
introduce a bill for a 20
tax on silicon valley and that bill
passes
guess what i can't introduce that bill
again and shake down silicon valley
i actually want the bill to fail um one
of the reasons that you see a lot of tax
credits
uh that are passed for example in 1981
congress passed a bill
for an r d tax credit for companies to
invest in research and development
people wonder in in the business
committee why is that tax credit never
been made permanent
well the reason they ask that question
is they're not thinking
uh about this as a shakedown if they
make
the tax credit permanent a congressman
can't go back to them and ask them for
money when they have to extend it
so they have these things called tax
extenders we're going to extend the tax
credit
for two to three years uh and then
what's going to happen is
they're going to have to come they're
going to meet with me they're going to
raise more money with me and then i'm
going to vote to extend it
for another couple of years but i'm
never going to make it permanent because
if i make it permanent
i lose my leverage in my ability to
extract money from
you